I started out as a kid reading sci-fi
and fantasy books and really loving them
I was also good at mathematics in school
when in high school I started taking my
first physics classes and finding out
that the mathematics I was learning and
kind of developing a facility with
actually applied to describe our
physical world much like magic underlies
Science Fiction and Fantasy stories
quite often it was really fantastic it's
like wow there is a magical language
underneath our universe and it's math
that was just the moment of just diving
deeper deeper into mathematical physics
and how our world Works in different
ways that are fascinating
[Music]